one of the most astounding things about
this book is that it's your first book
how exactly did that happen did you
finish the manuscript and did you just
know who to give it to and kind of start
this whirlwind of success and getting it
out there I did it I actually my story
kind of starts with Twitter of all
things you know um I was not sure if
this was even a book that could be
published because you don't see a lot of
books about young black girls you don't
see a lot of books about young black
girls dealing with racism and police
brutality and at the time where when you
say black lives matter so many people
don't really understand it I wasn't sure
if it was something that would be
accepted in publishing so I went on
Twitter a literary agency held a
question-and-answer session and I just
asked if it was an appropriate topic an
agent responded he was like I'd love to
read that and so I sent it to him he
loved it he signed me and now it's so
encouraging to for any you know creative
person out there that you know no matter
what your story is there's opportunities
to tell it which is very exciting also
fascinated because I do read a lot and I
always go out and try to read a book
before I see the movie that it's based
on and just the adaptation process
really fascinates me because you know
when you have a big fandom for a book
sometimes you could feel precious about
the book and you don't want to see it
change but film is a different medium so
curious if you guys have anything
specific that you changed in the movie
if you could tell me about that and why
you chose to do that um pretty much we
stayed faithful to the book as much as
possible there's a character that we
took out in the script in terms of the
pretty know the actual film production
we felt there was a lot of characters we
can maybe condense one that was really
done with the collaboration with Angie
making sure she felt comfortable with
that
in terms of a little bit of a structure
you know like the talk came a little bit
later we wanted to start off the movie
with the start with the talk and
establishing her worlds and Williamson
and Garden heights that was done a
little bit earlier I think Angie started
at the party but those are like small
things that you do anyway when you're
kind of adapting things but the tone the
spirit and the way these guys verbalize
and then communicate with each other we
want to be true today mm-hmm I think one
of the changes I'm most curious to hear
your opinion on is is the kiss in car I
am
it was interesting cuz I wasn't
expecting it and it happened and I can
see why you would do that but I'm just
curious what the conversation was like
when that idea came about I remember
when I read the script and they had that
happen I was like dang I should have
done that in the you know it's one of
those sweet tender moments that we get
right before tragedy and I think it's
important because if nothing else it
gives us gives the viewer of the movie
an even better idea of what this young
man means to start you know um you know
in the book books are different because
you're reading things and you I can just
say it I can have her say you know I
have feelings for Khalil but we actually
in the film we get to see it so I think
movies do a great job of showing instead
of telling so I loved that that was in
there do I hear about this uh monitor
dance you've got going on thank you